the only way you learn pressure is to
deal with pressure exactly
you got to get used to that [ __ ] gotta
feel her
know what she does how she tricks you
how she
messes with your head that's it messes
with your head you gotta learn that too
that's a that's the big one just like
you know essentially it's resistance
it's the same thing
that doubt that creeping doubt makes its
way
you got to figure out a way to find a
boy yeah and we're all
contributing to this uh collective
guidebook
of how to be a human yeah you know you
know one thing i've just recently
started playing with it occurred to me
that there's
little fears that we think of as trivial
and a trivial fear like a fear of
spiders or
and and there's also things like for
example for me i have this
block about doing a backflip on a
trampoline even like a super safe super
big one
and i can backflip into pools i can do
you know i'm a fairly
athletic guy but as soon as i go to do
it on a trampoline which is fairly soft
my body just freezes up and i lock and i
was talking to my friend
about it and for me you know when you
allow these fears that are
disproportionate away from the actual
danger
to take hold it's almost giving credence
you know giving resistance
like this little bit of victory that can
apply to other things or if you're
you know so afraid of spiders you can't
even look at it you know
just by doing that it's acknowledging
that you have some certain limitations
you know and it's giving that other
force that's going to limit you in life
and deny you from
achieving your goal just a little bit
more power so
even for me and this is something i'm
just recently playing with
these little trivial fears that we just
kind of avoid like ah this doesn't
matter you know who cares when am i
going to see a spider i don't know
i'll [ __ ] deal with it when it comes
or who cares if i do a backflip on a
trampoline you know
in effect it practically it doesn't
matter but as far as
doing the little things to battle
against these forces that are constantly
looking to confine us
i think maybe it matters you know like
maybe pushing through these seemingly
trivial things
it counts you know it's an exercise yeah
set yourself the task aubrey to do that
oh yeah for sure i decided that like
last like a few days ago i haven't been
home yet i'm walking out to the
trampoline
and i'm pushing through that moment
where my legs just say ah nobody
you're not doing this and i'm gonna do
it i hope i hope i can
i don't know but i'll see you i'll video
it or something i mean i figured out
i would guess that the backflip is a
metaphor for something else for you
stands for something right right um i
mean we all have that stuff for me it's
like claustrophobia
yeah you know elevators certain
elevators i can't get on
you know airplanes you know yeah and i
know
that it's it relates to other stuff you
know it's not
it's not isolated have you ever done a
sensory deprivation